so I'd like to introduce you to Paul
Sappho and and Paul will will tell you
more about John as as we get things
started on him but Paul is a member of
our board
he is a a futurist a prognosticator and
you're cutting into our time that's all
right and with that note Paul Sappho
ladies thank you and John is a promising
young tech writer here in Silicon Valley
who's just done a new book that we think
is going to do pretty well I truly think
that John does not need an introduction
though I promise to bring up a couple of
embarrassing details about him during
the conversation I thought we'd start
with a question to the audience and then
hand it to you to get things so just a
quick show of hands and we'll ask this
question again at the end as a test of
John's powers of persuasion raise your
hand if you think we're going to be
overwhelmed by our robot overlords in
some reasonable period in the future
that we're all doomed
AIS are going to take over show a hands
Jamis two three okay about five and who
thinks that robots will just become
loving unobtrusive companions in our
lives
[Laughter]
okay and we'll get to the rest of you
soon so okay John why I could I would
you like a first question or a first
question or I could just show this books
been a while in the making in this I
recall it goes back to what 2004 well so
what what Paul is saying is that we had
this tradition of taking field trips
we've had it for a long time we've gone
off and done various things we've landed
on aircraft carriers we've gone to
various Air Force facility we're still
trying to get into area 51 if anybody
has any contacts in 2004 we went to the
first DARPA Grand Challenge was the
autonomous vehicle Grand Challenge which
was held in the desert and we had just
an absolute great time and I think Paul
got amazing pictures of the robots
running amuck and it was it was it was
really a statement you know this contest
had been put together by the then
director of DARPA ma'am behemoth tawny
tether because he wanted Congress had
said this goal for a third of the ground
fleet of our military vehicles of being
autonomous or teleoperated by 2015
here we are in 2015 you'll notice that
that's not true it is true in air
vehicles but it's not true in land
vehicles which is I think interesting
but he wanted to jumpstart things and so
he thought he you know get away from the
military contracting world then he'd
turn it loose to the hackers and the
universities and the corporations and
the first event was an absolute disaster
I think there were 13 competitors I
think the before competitors the first
person yeah 24 there 24 they all ended
up dead in the desert the best the best
vehicle was a Carnegie Mellon car put
together a team put together by red
Whittaker and it made it for seven miles
but Paul got these great pictures which
I didn't bring it's too bad it was it
was missing the road for miles before it
extra through a fence on its way out
yeah on both sides of the road and there
was a wonderful motorcycle that was
gyroscopically stabilized that entered
in
the kid who designed it and rule 11 desk
II forgot to turn on the gyrostabilizer
at the beginning and it went like that
and Paul got us a ride in this airplane
afterwards and the colorful robots were
spread out over the desert
I just fell in love with this as a sort
of a new area of reporting I had for
decades literally been covering
cybersecurity and even in 2004 it was
just getting more and more tedious and I
began to feel like if I wrote one more
story about a testosterone poisoned
teenager with an aunt and attitude I was
going to have an aneurysm and I needed
to do something else and robots and AI
were fun and so I did a lot of reporting
of it over the next 10 years and at a
certain point I realized that this book
is not a sequel to my previous book
which was about stuff that happened
right around Stanford between 1965 and
1975 and it was a prehistory of personal
computing but there was a point of
connection and the point of connection
was that in the last book I noticed it
right at the dawn of interactive
computing there were these two
laboratories that were started roughly
at the same time on either side of
Stanford campus equidistant from the
campus one was created by a man by named
John McCarthy who had coined the term
artificial intelligence in the 1950s and
came from MIT in the 1960s in the
established two Stanford AI lab and at
that point in the original proposal of
DARPA he said it would take a decade to
build a thinking machine that was the
time horizon they had to replace a human
and on the other side of campus of
course there was the augmentation
Research Center which was started by
Doug Engelbart Engelbart of course had
had invented I would invent the computer
mouse and hypertext and angle Bart had
this idea that you could use these these
technologies to augment human
intelligence and I realized that these
were two contradictory philosophies and
in fact if you looked at what happened
in the intervening period they created
two communities one was the AI community
that continued to sort of try to replace
all of the sort of attributes that we
have and the other sort of coalesced
around this field called human-computer
interaction HCI and in that field they
put the human at the center of the
design process
and I saw that it was not just a
dichotomy but it was a paradox of course
because if you admit the human in
practice you need fewer humans and so I
set out to try to square that circle and
the book is sort of an exercise in
looking and a series of people who have
chosen to cross over or not a lot of
people were you know the classic example
is Terry Winograd who was a pioneering
AI researcher as a graduate student he
wrote this program called shrewd Lou
which was a natural language
understanding program in which you could
basically interact with a software
program to move blocks in a virtual
universe and he spent the next ten years
basically engaged trying to sort of
pursue the field of artificial
intelligence and then sort of famously
in the in the early 1980s he gave up and
he walked away and he became a
researcher in the field of
human-computer interaction and to my
mind this was this incredibly important
art because Terry had this really
seminal influence in the world it was
Terry Winograd as the adviser to Larry
Page who convinced Larry Page that he
should work on the PageRank algorithm
you should work on search rather than
working on self-driving cars so that was
something that sort of changed the world
in a really interesting way and I had
looked at sir like that scene in the
graduate plastic plastics today I would
say metamaterials not a material absent
yeah you've heard about your story yes
so I you know I looked at probably a
dozen or more people who'd made
decisions one way or the other and you
know at the sort of very basis of my
perspective on what's going on in
Silicon Valley in the world is you know
I think the field is called the social
construction of technology I believe
that you know as
you know this is Churchill and then more
recently who Churchill and who's the
mean Lady Astor we shape our buildings
and then they shape us my clue first we
yes we make we create our technologies
and we turn around our user knowledge is
great basically the tools that we shape
and that was what interested me that's
where I got started and sort of where I
finished this way Jim let's head off
into the future a second but go back a
little bit to the histories I think the
place in your book where you talk about
how John McCarthy came up with the name
AI which was probably I'm sure most
people don't know the story it was just
one of these wonderful cases of academic
kind of yeah yes been lost in history
but I sort of I was very intrigued by
Norbert Wiener and you know Weiner
basically at the very dawn of computing
he created this this term cybernetics
which was the study of communication
control in the human in that and the
animal and he wrote this book
cybernetics in 48 about the same time
that the the computer was invented and
then three years later he was kind of a
gas by what might happen he wrote a
second book called the human use of
human beings and Wiener was an
interesting character on so many levels
I mean he's sort of defined the term
absent-minded professor one of the
things I discovered which i think is
actually sort of academic scholarship I
haven't been able to find it anywhere
else is where did the term artificial
intelligence come from and I was reading
in John McCarthy's archive and of course
the term artificial intelligence was
coined by John McCarthy ahead of 1956
Dartmouth summer study group on AI and
McCarthy is very direct
he created the term artificial
intelligence because one he didn't like
the term cybernetics he thought that it
was far too analog which is very
interesting and in terms of where we are
now and the importance of analog
the rise of robotics and he particularly
didn't like Weiner he thought Weiner was
a bore and bombastic and he wanted
nothing to do with him and so he coined
a term to define this new field which is
already flushing tell us of course
cybernetics in part because I think of
weiners politics was sort of driven to
the side and it you know it's a field in
in Europe not so much in America today
well McCarthy really rejected the
defense community where Weiner was sort
of planned no no it was Weiner
he took defense money all the way I
don't think he was a big fan of the
military but he was happy to take their
money look McCarthy started as a
communist but that's an entirely other
story which we probably that's that's
the last book we don't need to go down
this and then famously turned and became
a conservative at the end of his life as
Samuel Johnson once observed nothing
resembles a hollow so much as a swelling
so you know it was sort of sitting out
those two communities and trying to
understand how they interact and sort of
using this as a model for sort of making
the argument that human design matters
going forward and that you know we are
at the end of designing these systems I
was at this really remarkable conference
in 2013 there's a conference every year
on humanoid robots and robot assist by
the name of Ron Arkin who's also an
ethicist gave a talk at this conference
which is basically a 200 leading
roboticists in in the world basically
the talk was titled how not to create a
terminator and he and this was in the
midst of the DARPA Robotics Challenge
which of course was the follow-on
conference to the autonomous vehicle
challenge and in this case a DARPA
program manager had had created this
idea that you would you would build a
machine that could work in a Fukushima
like environment where humans couldn't
work and there were there were two
contests unlike the the DARPA autonomous
vehicle contest and this was this was
before the first contest that he gave
this talk and he sort of put up a series
of videos and he basically showed all
the examples that were sort of the eight
tasks that you had to perform in this
DARPA contest you had to drive a vehicle
you had to walk you
open a door and pass through it you had
to close a valve you had to walk over
uneven ground throw a switch and climb a
ladder and and he basically put up the
videos of all the sort of terminator
like you know thing and came up with the
best defense against the Terminator
which is oh no no you mean that that's
at the very end yes well so it's jumping
ahead sorry so so you know we just we
had the the first and then the second of
these contests the second one was held
this this summer in in Los Angeles and
it was really remarkable to me it
clearer than anything else is ground
truth of where we are in terms of
robotics and an odd structure world we
had 24 teams who were given millions of
dollars in funding in several years to
build robots to sort of pursue these
goals and three of the robots were able
to actually accomplish the task but most
of them couldn't in fact most of them
couldn't open the door
and so Gill Pratt son as a college
student turned to rod Brooks and said
you know if you're worried about the
Terminator just keep your door closed
there's more truth to that because when
you start to sort of then you you would
think as if you drill down into the
field reports of those teams they're you
know they're the best roboticist in the
world given millions of dollars to
basically design robots that are
supposed to be able to do things in
unstructured environments and they were
almost entirely teleoperated there was
very very little autonomy and used by
any of the teams and DARPA made it hard
because they they'd sort of scramble
things everyone so on so the team spaces
the machines couldn't couldn't operate
they had some very low-level walking
behavior and you know I mean actually
some should we show some slides or so it
shows some videos so let me where's just
in case we need technical help my quest
and by this'll work so this is this is
Boston Dynamics which is a which is a
tap of a second time
oops
no sorry how about that wait is there a
robot in the house okay
hands off really so this is a machine
that's designed by a company that was
started by my flavors arguably the best
designer of washing machines in the year
Boston Dynamics of course was acquired
by Andy Rubin when he was building a
robot division for Google two years ago
and this is an evolved version that was
actually sort of a machine that was
originally designed for the Pentagon
that's now a legal in Massachusetts and
then it's been refined for Google inland
when Andy was going around the country
his vision and buying he acquired about
13 companies his vision was the Google
delivery vehicle would show up at your
door and the gleam of the robot would
hop off the back and run the package up
here up here your mailbox and so but
what you don't see there is the guy with
a backpack and the wireless controller
see these these machines look autonomous
and there is a lower level of autonomy I
mean the fact that it can climb those
stairs like that is incredibly
impressive but there was family it was
breaking news you probably didn't use
here today I there was proof that low
levels of autonomy questell operation
can be very profitable somebody in
Nogales had 23 pounds of pot drop into
their backyard that fell off a Mexican
drug drone bringing it into the US but
okay so this is a highly korva busted
dynamic video but here here are the
outtakes from this dark monroebot extent
Oh
[Music]
the designers that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't laugh at your overlords
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's where we are today just for
context so that brings up a question
that I thought would come up later but I
think now it's a really good time parts
of this well way back in the 60s as you
note in your book Hubert Dreyfus his
famous rejoinder to the enthusiasts was
that progress in this field was like you
know climbing a tree and saying I'm
pretty well on my way to the moon yeah
parts of this feel exponential so the
arc of the robotic grand challenge out
and the desert went from you know robots
failing spectacularly in 2004 to robots
in 2007 robotic cars demonstrating that
they understood the California Vehicle
Code better than 98% of Californians and
that looks pretty exponential but I've
become a skeptic on Exponential's
so this is it so so how is this so I
actually think progress in this field
has been really episodic and in fact AI
over a long period of time perhaps more
than any other field I know has
over-promised and under-delivered you
know going back to McCarthy's original
sort of prognosis of a decade even
before they just didn't mention which
decade that's right in 58 when the first
neural net was it was demonstrated the
New York Times article that appeared to
report about it
said that they would have Thinking
Machines in a year there was the AI
winner when a whole series of companies
started in Silicon Valley which Paul
knows about intimately because he was
general counsel for one of them
technology you know there was a there
was a great watch that now what's
happened is that we've reached a period
because of the success of the variety of
machine learning technologies we've made
very rapid progress in perception note
though there's no disputing a machines
are starting to see and machines are
starting to listen
cognition not so much the so far the
various
technologies have have not made great
strides and the kinds of things you have
to do in an unstructured environment and
you know they may make that progress but
when people say Exponential's you have
you know we have this notion of the
singularity for example which of course
was originally proposed by John van
Wyman and then sort of sort of
popularized by Vernor Vinge the computer
science and science fiction author and
so by their measurement we're supposed
to be an intelligent machines but what's
the current number 2023 2027 it's really
a point at which three thousand or 2,000
supposed to surpass human intelligence
and so my forecast by the way when we
finally have machines that pass the
Turing test the real discovery will be
that most humans can't pass the session
but you have people like Jeff Hawkins
and and Ray Kurzweil in Silicon Valley
who basically believe that we understand
human biological cognition they're sort
of I would argue they're reductionist
but they their argument is we understand
the fundamental algorithms that have you
know go on in the cortex and we simply
need to scale it up and you know I when
you talk to the neuroscientists in the
world you just that's just not what the
neuroscientists community near science
community believes and then couple that
with the fact that the basically the
wheels are falling off Moore's law right
now so that notion of you know what
we're seeing as an s-curve we're seeing
a really interesting part of an s-curve
and the attributes of Moore's Law that
have sort of you know the Silicon
Valley's belief structure has been built
out they're no longer holding true
Dennard scaling or that is the increase
in clock speeds stopped a decade ago
more importantly over the last two or
three years you know machines were
supposed to get faster not just fast
they're supposed to get faster faster so
clock speeds flattened out that's not
true they're also supposed to get
cheaper faster and that's been the
driving force in Silicon Valley over a
long long period except over the last
year or two the cost of transistors for
the vast bulk of the industry has
stopped falling so if those two things
are gone then that wonderful exponential
goodness that we've gotten the free
right under silicon
Vallely for decades is is over and so
you know you're down to creative
breakthroughs from human beings to get
us farther and that may happen you know
I there's there's a lot of interesting
stuff going on by the way it was a nice
article about this in the New York Times
yesterday a couple of days couple of
days ago which I recommend reading
because it's also mentioned the book is
that Gordon Moore and his conceiving of
Moore's law was hugely original but he
was sitting in the audience back in the
1950s when well so you know the very
first moment of sort of understanding
the idea that would become Moore's law
is this notion that Doug Engelbart first
proposed at the very first international
solid-state circuit conference in
Philadelphia in 1960 he had worked
interestingly in NASA NASA Ames window
and he discovered that the aeronautical
engineers had this ayat' notion or this
tool called similitude and they would
build a small model and scale it up and
so when photolithography came along in
1959 1960 realized obviously that you
would could also scale things down and
he gave this talk in in 19 1960 and and
war was in the audience in five years
later in electronics he codified it and
it became called Moore's law thereafter
and it's held true you know you get this
doubling of transistor density at
regular intervals of course the
intervals have changed over the time
it's not a law of physics it's about an
ecosystem and it's this it's it's been
this very effective signaling mechanism
that's kept this industry going and the
other thing that's happened is that you
know Intel dismissed Intel famously for
decades wears on this tick-tock a design
process one year they drink the
technology the next year they create a
new design and they for the first time
in two decades miss this just a couple
of months ago it's now tick tock tock
and so it's gone from two years to two
and a half or three years even for the
best world so I'm not gonna lie we're
gonna come back to us cuz I'm not gonna
let you off the hook in terms of
predicting how soon the robots actually
arrive and and also similarly how soon
we will actually get augmentation
tools beyond spreadsheets and word
processor but the other thing it seems
like has been very consistent is public
fascination with this so I brought a
copy of roar Rossum's Universal robots
1923 which is this is the play that gave
us the name robot and public fascination
of the 20s with robots doing wonderful
things was really high and then we get
to the early 30s and one of my favorite
magazines that lasted one issue the
technocratic a little hard to see well
put this up on the page that big robot
throwing people over the top of the
Capitol I'm hoping those that's members
of Congress so it seems like so we're
about every 10 15 years we have this
funny cycle of we we go from ignoring
robots to be thrilled by robots to being
terrified by robots to ignoring robots
and right now we're in the midst of this
robot fascination well it's also it's
also technologically anxiety I mean
there been a series of books that all
sort of play on the notion that we're
gonna have a tremendous disruption of
the work force over the next decade or
two decades as a result of progress and
AI and I started in that camp I'm a
matter of fact I was part of the problem
I I think in probably 2010 I began
seeing that this pattern recognition
technology that was beginning to work
was starting to sort of creep its way up
the white collar workforce and for the
first time you're getting $35 an hour
paralegals and foreigner dollar now our
attorneys who are being displaced by
e-discovery software that could do a
demonstrable a better job of reading
documents than humans could you could
actually see that's the really insulting
part is you get a law degree you know
all that hard work and you're not even
replaced by an artificial intelligence
you're replaced by a piece of form
software very true but but you know
what's happened is this did you know
this is this has happened at regular
intervals in our society and sort of
sadly Jeremy Rifkin this economist wrote
a book in 1995 called the end of work
and in the ensuing decade that the the
workforce grew more robustly than it had
for the previous two decades so it's
very you have to pick your spots and be
careful but you gotta give Jeremy credit
I mean Jeremy has made a career of
hitting a large nail not quite on the
head but he usually tries to hit the
nail about 15 or 20 years they had
everyone else well he's taking victory
laps now from what I've heard that he's
saying that you know this time for sure
rocky and bullwinkle no trick never
works
III really actually even more than why
not you know the you you finish a book
and then a year goes by before it's
published and I've come you know I
raised a lot of questions that sort of
set me apart from people like Andrew
McAfee and Eric brindle son Martin Ford
Jerry Jerry Kaplan who've all sort of
worried that this wave of technology is
going to destroy jobs unless and I was
in that camp and you know actually what
what
there was one conversation that really
moved me away from that and it was with
Danny Kahneman and I was sort of at you
know with him my hair was on fire about
the impact of robotics and manufacturing
in China and he said you don't get it in
China the robots are gonna come just in
time nice excuse me
and he pointed out to me that China is a
society that is aging much more
dramatically than ours they don't have
immigration they have a one-child policy
to South 2017 s the key here what
happens is that's when the flip starts
with the Chinese population and by 2026
and of course the Japanese society is
actually imploding they're gonna lose a
third of their population it's true in
Korea it's true in Europe not so much in
the u.s. because we have immigration
which is really yeah the United States
has been said it will be the Dorian
otherwise but even we're an aging
economy and the point is that you know
the dependency ratio is is gonna
increase all over the advanced world and
that's gonna change the dynamic you
can't take a snapshot you have to look
at this as something that's dynamic plus
because we're gonna have this dependent
population you might actually need elder
care robots at some point in the future
so you mentioned the Japanese and
they've had a very special relationship
with robots that I think is unequaled by
any other population a love affair a
love affair oh absolutely say yes but we
won't go there
what about this scenario that we all
desperately want the robots and they
don't arrive well so okay so I I'm
making these bets I do not so long bets
but they're kind of one bit well we'll
talk about that afterwards you know for
me a benchmark would be a robot that
could care for an elder who needed to
take a shower that's a really
challenging thing and the Europeans have
basically put down a billion euros on a
project to do just that and it's not
clear that we're gonna get there within
my lifetime you know the the other sort
of classic one you know thank God nerds
in Silicon Valley learned to start
showering about 15 years ago so this was
the second autonomous vehicle Grand
Challenge and that's Sebastian Thrun and
the car just driven off the road into a
giant bush which is actually the the
best possible outcome for a reporter is
a robot crashes and you can walk away
from the crash it gives you a lead but
you know what most people don't really
mean I was not at Google's announcement
today they had another sort of press
event about their self-driving car
project and they did the same thing
about six months ago and what people
don't realize is Google sort of split
their car program and they created a
second car program around vehicles that
go no faster than 25 miles an hour and
are heavily wrapped in foam in case they
hit something with plastic windshields
and they're loose all over Mountain View
and their Castro Street Mountain View
it's getting so bad I was caught in a
robot traffic jam on my way to
singularity University about two weeks
ago but I've been going around saying
look it I live in San Francisco if you
can send a Google car or a Tesla car to
me I pick me up and take me to dinner in
Palo Alto in nineteen twenty five twenty
twenty-five I'm buying dinner so ten
years from now I think there are just
too many edge cases and the liability
issues are too strong we're gonna we're
gonna have cars with lots of
intelligence in them but I don't believe
we're gonna have
you know free-range self-driving cars
and by the way when when that robots
available to take you to dinner here's
my forecast is there will you know most
of us won't own robotic cars we all know
that story but there will be the 1% of
the 1% who will have to have their
robotic cars you like the Mercedes
concept car that looks like a moving
blob of mercury and what they will do is
they will solve the san francisco
parking problem as follows
they will have the car drop them off and
rather than pay for parking for their
robotic car they'll have their robot car
cruising around San Francisco so we're
gonna have a street full of empty
robotic cars keeping themselves occupied
while they're there
owners have dinner at Dominique Krenz
well look at so what Google discovered
is you know they started out with
professional drivers who watched over
the cars and they were it didn't
spectacularly well I think they're 1.2
million miles without accan without a
computer caused accident but at a
certain point at the beginning of this
year they began to give their cars to
their employees to commute with and they
instrumented the cars and watch them and
what they discovered is that the at the
end of a long day their employees got to
it got distracted up to an including
falling asleep and this is what's called
the handoff problem if you're asleep or
you're playing World of Warcraft and the
car gives up on a particular edge case
incident and says here you take control
that's called that's called the handoff
problem and it's you know you have to be
in situational awareness within a
quarter of a second it's just not gonna
happen it's just and so it's very
interesting that Toyota about three
weeks ago gave 25 million dollars to the
Stanford AI lab and the MIT I lay AI lab
not to work on self-driving cars but to
work on what they call intelligence cars
and this is basically an AI versus AI a
dichotomy they've decided that they're
going to work on a generation of cars
that will keep you in the loop but will
put us a sort of a genie or a guardian
angel or a driver ed teacher over your
shoulder and so when you do something
dumb the car will step in and correct
your error and I think that's a much
more solvable problem than the notion of
putting freight liners on the freeway
well you know without humans apropo you
know bill Gibson the futures already
arrived it's not evenly
tributed yet that's not a future
scenario we all trust our lives to
robots in transport today
anybody who flies in the commercial jet
340 or a triple 7 flying at altitude is
not being flown by a human a human being
cannot fly that plane to optimize speed
angle of attack and there's something
called the coffin corner
you know what the common core tourism
it's the speed for an airplane above
which the plane starts to fly apart and
below which the plane starts to fall and
crash and for the u2 that it's altitude
the coffin corners about 5 knots between
stall and breakup well turns out the
a340 is about 20 knots and if you want a
case in point of the hand-off problem it
was Air France 447 in 2008 which in less
than 9 minutes went from routine normal
flight to hitting the ocean
the pilots figured it out what was wrong
but they figured it out 30 seconds too
late because the software on that plane
did a lousy hand eye but you know a
little bit more on the employment hold
that but I want to ask you a questions
but what was them I think I know the
moment but the when was the moment that
was the scariest moment in researching
this book was it on the road to the Dead
Sea actually it was a little freaky I
there's an Israeli company that supplies
camera technology the two most of those
sort of tier one of automobile
manufacturers and they want to get into
the self-driving cars world themselves
and they have a particular design that
the camera gets its structure of the
world from motion because it's it's
monocular it's not stereoscopic and so
the car when it starts up goes back and
forth like this which is a little
disconcerting actually that was the that
was the most interesting do you have a
video of one of these I do
we should I'm gonna invite questions
from the audience and and here's how it
works if you have a question ask it as a
question if you have a comment don't
waste your time trying to make it a
question
but either way try and make it brief and
pointed so that John can you know give
an answer and we can get in a bunch and
I'll filter them in here as we go and
just sort of you know one more point on
the manufacturing or the robotics thing
this one is fun because there's another
one of the companies that was bought by
but by by Google this is a company in
Palo Alto called industrial perception I
know if I hit the button one more time
that's nice
ha
[Music]
[Applause]
that was your new iPad and what was
interesting about that is that was made
possible by the Xbox basically there was
a sensor on a structured light sensor
that was allowed designed to allow you
to do interesting things in your living
room and that pushed the cost of machine
vision technology down dramatically by
an order of magnitude and it began to
show up in interesting applications like
this
so the deal was when they were before
they were bought by Google and they were
trying to negotiate with the United
Parcel Service a human moves about one
box every six seconds they weigh up to
70 pounds they get tired the backs get
hurt they would get the contract at four
seconds and they were at four seconds
when they were acquired by Google and
they thought they could go to two
seconds and you know there aren't that
many people it turns out in the world
are the workforce the the labor force of
people to do that now it's about 70,000
people so there aren't that many jobs
but you know that's one of those things
that is it's the world a worse place if
that job goes away as long as they're
retrained same word about Amazon well so
we so Amazon has gone down this path
with the technology that they bought
from a company called Kibo they're the
two types of sort of retrieval of
products inside warehouses one's called
case pick where they move cases of goods
around the other is called piece pick
where they move the individual and in
the in the old warehouses in the Amazon
situation the workers would run around
the warehouses and they would grab
things then bring back put blocks they
bought a company called Kiva and that
the notion the Kiva's pursue in terms of
automation is they realize the things
they couldn't replace our dexterity and
vision and so in the Kiva model of the
world the human sits in one place and
the robots bring the right product to
the right place at the right time and of
course Amazon is working very hard on
sort of taking the humans out of out of
the loop and the the joke is when the
robots finally come to the Amazon
warehouse they'll have to have air
conditioning because but they're not
there yet
because those turn out to be hard
problems they sponsored a contest this
year at a technical technical conference
in Seattle and it's clear that picking
individual products out of bins is still
not a solved problem for dexterity and
for object recognition reasons oh it's
not bad thing of mutual friend of ours
got 7 free computers from Amazon because
they shipped her the wrong package and
they had no process for computer error
human there yeah no a good question
either way they wouldn't take him back
so question Brian
[Music]
yeah well Ryan I have I have the
horrible task of having to repeat your
question for everyone so give me the
Haiku version then I won't repeat it
okay so we think of Elon Musk as
challenge around protection so famously
said that we're in danger of summoning
the demon Stephen Hawking has said
similar things Bill Gates has worried
about AI independent intelligence and
you know I guess I one is I think that
they've performed it really important
service but not because I think the
machines are gonna crawl out of the test
tube
any time soon I think certainly not out
of Microsoft I don't think there's any
evidence that we're close to sentient
machines however increasingly we
machines are making autonomous decisions
from weapons to the workplace and I
think the discussion about autonomy and
machines is an important one to have and
they've in the it's what's it called the
foundation of life they set up an
organization I'm blanking on the name
right now and it's raising all the right
questions we are on the brink of
building of machines that make killing
decisions and I think we should have a
discussion about that before we go down
that path the United States is in the
process of deploying what they call a
semi autonomous cruise missile right now
there's a debate about how semi and how
autonomous it actually is and you know I
think we're on the cusp of a really
significant arms race and before we
enter into that arms race we I don't
think it's in your book but you should
tell the story about what happened in
South Africa with the autonomous gun oh
this is way back in the 90s they were
proudly showing off I won't mention the
company name because it gave me was he a
Don Imus high-powered gun and they had
lots of dignitaries there to watch it
and the gun went off wrong like check
out all the dignitaries it really sucks
when you have to kill your cousin there
is an argument that's being made that
autonomous weapons won't create war
crimes that you will actually be able to
kill who you want to kill
I actually don't subscribe to that
argument but that is that is the nature
of the debate question here
um stand up and project so I in the book
I try to there are a number of examples
of sort of people who've crossed over
and basically using AI technologies for
AI a for ia design and the classic one
to mine oh I'm sorry
AI is artificial intelligence and Doug
Engelbart coined the term intelligence
augmentation I a and and so if you look
at a service like Siri Siri is a classic
example of machines acting as partners
to humans and I think that's sort of the
the best case of where that design might
go and it's touching
you know the lives of hundreds of
millions of people right now at Google
search the same thing it's an ia example
so you know I'm actually hopeful you
know and I think it's a it's a design
question the humans make these decisions
and sometimes they're made just for cost
reasons and sometimes we should automate
things but we should think about it
consciously of what we automate and what
we don't automate and you know there
there are there's a set of human values
that should be in place in the design
process so I realize we've really can I
a short shrift in this conversation and
of course the title of your book refers
to a poem that so brilliantly summarizes
I a do you want to okay so this is
Richard Brautigan poem and the relevant
passage at the very end of us I'd like
to think of a cybernetic ecology where
we are free of our labors joined back to
nature return to our mammals brothers
and sisters and all watched over by
machines of loving grace describe the AI
I mean we all kind of know what the
artificial intelligence world would be
like if it really arrived
what's the ia world look like if it
actually arrives
you know I'm so religious about you know
what the great thing about being a
reporter is you just have to jot down
what the visionaries say you don't
actually have
like stake out the ground right this is
also the I'm not real good at pool but I
like to play for money
[Laughter]
you know I've been having this let me
let me treat it seriously because I've
been having this debate within my family
my wife is caring for her 94 year old
father with Parkinson's right now and
you know the sort of the vision that I
have is if you could and you know when
you actually have to do the care for
your parent it really sort of sharpens a
lot of issues for you
and the question is I mean so that the
hope is that these machines could allow
people who become dependent and go into
assisted living facilities to stay
independent and have a community longer
and I can actually see that design I
could also see a design that became very
dark and very believe there's a new book
that's also come out by sherry Turkle
who sort of argues that we're plunging
into a world where we're lated from one
another and in conversation with
machines and that's sort of the dark
vision that's implicit in that I don't
think it has to be that way although I
could see it going in that direct that
was of course so brilliantly done whole
earth review I think was the computers
as poison issue reprinting EM Forster's
marvellous short story the machine stops
isn't that yeah so I mean by the way I
just want to note there are all sorts of
people in this room who were more than
bystanders in this whole revolution
story Brandin particular has had this
amazing pattern of popping up if you
read back through the history of this
stuff he like pops up at every critical
juncture in this whole thing except
possibly the 1956 artificial
intelligence conference so story do you
have a question or a comment
turn this around is 70 years 56 yeah
[Music]
forwarding the synthetic biology
synthetic is a different turn than other
people I wonder if at some point where
all of this is going is gone far enough
they originally thought the language
well the field is moving away from I
mean the Turing test I think has really
turned out to be a test of human
gullibility
it says much more about us than it does
about the machines and so the field over
the last year sparked by the Emil Guzman
incident where somebody designed some
Soviet Russian and Ukrainian programmers
designed a program that played the part
of a 14 year old boy and it fooled
enough people in in England that they
decided it's easier to simulate a 14
year old boy than a 14 year old girl a
lot easier but the current thinking is
that just as with humans we don't have a
single intelligent test we have a series
of different tests that test different
capabilities of humans but the AI field
seems to be going in that direction now
there there are people argue that we
should give the Machine standardized
tests one example is giving them an SAT
test another example is giving them what
is called the IKEA assembly challenged
well on this this terminology thing
you're a wordsmith his Stuart makes a
really good point that it's quite
astonishing that our machines you know
we've had all the doubling magic of
Moore's law and all these wonders and
things but we're still using the same
language that was all invented in the
50s mean the word automation was
invented by a Ford executive and he was
just talking about putting cars together
and yet we still use that AI is from the
Cold War we still use that ia
we still use that I kind of like
cybernetics because you know it's the
Greek steersman a lot but how come we
don't
new vocabulary well there's been
attempts I mean I like synthetic
intelligence we should note that it
happened here tonight if it can't do it
planned if it catches on you know what
causes phrases to catch on people have
talked about the idea of artificial
general intelligence as being full human
level intelligence and there's still
some there still a large number of
technologists who believe that that is
yeah that's debate narrow AI versus
artificial intelligence we had a
question back here projects so I don't
have to repeat yeah so we're turning
these these techniques pattern
recognition techniques in this case
loose on all kinds of different
applications throughout society and I
think one of the best critics of this is
an HCI guy whose name is ben shneiderman
who has written widely about the
separation of humans from the machine
and if we delegate these tasks the
machine and we take the humans away from
the loop we basically raise the
possibility of basic essentially
allowing the machines to work without
ethics which is interesting in the
context of the Three Laws of Robotics
which we haven't talked about here and
largely I'm sort of falling off the yeah
it's amazing I mean who's heard the
three bozo mobs Three Laws of Robotics
mentioned lately yeah the nerd quadrant
over here but and oh right sorry
but I don't speak robot so we're in
we're in we're letting decision-making
increasingly into these algorithms and
giving them to machines look at what
happened to Volkswagen for God's sakes
this is I think a harbinger of what
what's going to come and so wherever
this code is running you're gonna run
into those kinds of situations because
there are there is human intent and
decision-making embedded in these
systems which perhaps separated from
towhen control
let me I'm going to come to stand over
there you at you've had your question
for a while so then we'll go to Xandar
oh that's easy what's the error rate of
robotic cars versus human drivers well I
think you've got the stats it Google has
made strong claims I you know the
problem is the edge cases are the
imponderables that they I mean the error
rates in driving on the freeway are
probably good enough that right now you
would rather have a computer driving
than a human already and you know Elon
Musk continues to say that he's going to
have self-driving Tesla's I'm not quite
sure what he means and how soon your
Tesla is going to be able to come from
the garage and pick you up and take you
home
you know I'm hedging because I don't
have a meaningful answer but it if it
depends it depends on whether it's
raining in which case the balancers tend
to get confused I mean how do you
measure that just note that remarkable
coincidence in 2007 20 minutes before
the robotic urban Grand Challenge
started two hundred miles to the north
and Fresno there was a hundred eighteen
vehicle pileup of cars driving through
the tule fog that is there regularly and
still people wouldn't slow down and one
of the paramedic fire captain's said it
was a strangest thing as we were
rescuing people from the front we could
hear the cars smashing in the pack back
and I'm reminded this every time on 280
people shouldn't drive
sure Google has that information I don't
believe they've made anything public
except for their accident rate so I
can't really come up with the kind of
you know granular information here let's
go to Xandar
we're on the fun part of this by the way
I was going to say his Xander's his
evenings and weekends he builds killer
robots award-winning killer robots
human hours into it but you get this
exponential growth
whereas the completion of those two now
well also the environments they operate
in in air space and cyber we're gonna
have autonomous vehicles no question
about it we already do ground a harder
problem which is where you're living in
right but are you're satelli operator or
autonomous how many did you kill this
weekend just came fast from a race um
did the gentleman next you have a
question no no one over look Joe do that
one question I have a final question for
you because we're right at the end of
our time go ahead
no pressure
[Music]
patience or
ilan amazes me I've toured SpaceX and
the fact that he can harness the
industrial resources he does on the
scale that he does and and people tell
me he's a terrible manager how does he
do this I mean I so to that point you
know he's achieved an extraordinary
amount of things I don't know how he's
gonna get to self-driving cars in three
years I think he if he's talking about
things like super cruise I mean he's
gonna have it next year GM's gonna have
it you know your machine will be driving
itself but I believe you're gonna have
to put your hand on the wheel every 10
seconds or it's gonna drop out of that
mode so I'm not you know so you're not
going to be able to climb into the
backseat we're gonna I'm a moderators
privilege I'm going to cram two
questions into the very end here apropos
of Elon so besides Elon you you just
finished doing this walkabout through
the robotic augmentation landscape who
should we watch is there one person in
particular besides Elon
well I would watch Google I mean I would
watch Cooper's there's a whole I mean
there were 13 really world-class
robotics what about the guy that you
couldn't write about in the book well I
know I know no that's Andy Rubin yeah
Andy you know Andy who is the guy who
put together Google's robot division and
then left shortly thereafter I mean he
start things he starts things really
well he doesn't run things really well
and that's what happened is that he grew
bored after he put the team together and
he realized it was like a 15 year long
march to get to where he wanted to go
and he and he left
but mark raybert is remarkable the guy
who well we could we could end on yeah
well no I have a question and I thought
what was shown a bit though this is also
highly scripted the first ballet robot
[Music]
so last quick question is what if you
had to offer up one surprise that we
should be on the watch out for and I'm
gonna give you a second to think about
this you got to really think I'm gonna
give you one Karl topic one of the most
surprising things I ever heard about
robots in 1923 I wasn't there in 1923
but at the very end of Rossum's
Universal robots there's a scene where
the robots are confronting one of the
last humans left and it basically says
sir have pity terror is coming upon us
we have intensified our labor eight
million robots have died within the year
within 20 years none will be left sir
the world is dying out human beings knew
the secret of life tell us their secret
if you do not tell us we should perish
so for me the surprise is maybe the
robots arrived and then it turns out
they're lonely for humans what's your
surprise that's a lot like Blade Runner
but I just yes so cloud robotics is is
the potential game changer people like
Ken Goldberg Berkley or James Kutner at
Google have this notion that you know
you teach one robot and all robots
immediately have that skill that you've
taught them and that kind of a scale up
or they all pick up this even all of a
sudden one learns how to smoke and
they're all still hanging out on street
party I'll go to the beach yeah because
they're self-aware that's what you would
do if you could let my robots go surfing
cloud robotics is really an interesting
the fact that you can leverage one bit
of machine learning
to all the robots in the world this is
we're right at the end of the time let's
give John a bit
[Applause]
[Music]